warning this video contains cold Geass
spoilers all the spoilers all of them
[Music]
[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and this video is a
result of all the awesome comments and
feedback that we've been getting on our
recent Code Geass videos we also
recently hosted a special Code Geass
theories livestream right here on our
channel and a whole bunch of you guys
came and together we came up with the
theories that we are using in this video
so thank you guys for coming out
we are planning similar live streams for
Code Geass and a whole bunch of other
anime so if you're new to the channel
and you want to be a part of it feel
free to subscribe we'd love to have you
and without further ado number 10
Lelouch is immortal now this theory is
not so shocking anymore but it certainly
was when the series first finished
airing and the reason we're including it
here in number 10 is because it is the
basis for a whole bunch of other
theories according to this theory
Lelouch does not die when Suzaku stabs
him at the end of r2 instead Lelouch
survives because he has code
he is an immortal being there are two
different arguments for how la louche
obtained code the first and more popular
one is that he obtained that when he
killed Charles Charles got cold by
killing his brother V - and when Lelouch
kills Charles inside the world of see
the louche gets Charles's code from him
the second theory is that Lelouch got
his code from C - this means that c2
gave up her code and gave it to Lelouch
instead so that he could live personally
I prefer the Charles theory because in
the anime the only time we actually see
code transferring from one person to
another is when the original holder of
the cold dies so in the case of C - the
nun dies and in the case of Charles V -
dies
those who believe the C - theory
actually believe that a person with code
can transfer their code voluntarily to
another person they don't have to die to
do it but because we don't actually get
to see that in the anime and because I
won c2 in the lose to be immortal
together rather than one of them getting
old while the other doesn't I prefer to
Charles theory and if you'd like to see
a detailed analysis of the Lelouch
getting his quote from Charles theory
check out my top three reasons elucha
still alive video the link is in the
description
shout out to Rohan Saeed for his
contribution on this one
number nine Lelouch will give Geass
power to others if we accept the Lelouch
now has code that
means that he can give the power of
Geass to others through a contract he
could do it two characters that we
already know such as Suzaku or Colin or
he could do it to a bunch of brand-new
characters at any rate this would mean
that Lelouch could potentially become
the mentor and mastermind behind a whole
new generation of powerful Geass users
which would be pretty cool to see in the
sequel shout-out to Tyler Zaza and Ed
combs 108 for their feedback on this one
number eight Lelouch has both code and
Geass this is one that I actually didn't
think about at first but a whole bunch
of you commented and pointed this out to
me I mean look at all those comments
thank you guys
according to this theory if we assume
that Lelouch really got his code from
Charles and we know that he got his
Geass power to a contract with C 2
because C 2 is still alive this could
mean that Lelouch now possesses code and
Geass at the same time this is because
the fact that C 2 is still alive could
mean that the contract she has with
Lelouch is still valid and some argue
that the whole meaning behind the title
of Code Geass is pointing to the fact
that Lelouch now has both code and Geass
at the same time this is a really
interesting theory I like it a lot and
if it's true it means that Lelouch will
be an extremely powerful force in the
sequel in the new PV that recently
leaked for the sequel we do appear to
see Lelouch as I with Geass so that
could mean that this theory is in fact
true but we'll have to wait and find out
number 7 there will be a bloody civil
war in the Code Geass sequel this one
was proposed by vector Maximus and soul
maka and basically this theory states
that the powerful Nobles of Britannia
and other factions within the world of
Code Geass are going to rebel against
the zero Requiem and wage a bloody civil
war against the Black Knights and this
will be the major conflict in the Code
Geass equal Geass powers as well as
powerful new weapons could be part of
this Civil War and because Nunnally is
now the Empress of Britannia there is
also the potential that not only could
be kidnapped or even killed by one of
the
actions which would force the luge to
come out of hiding
another quick thank you to that Gundam
guy number six the sequel will feature a
fake zero or an imposter zero in the
original series we are repeatedly told
that zero is a mask a symbol and we know
that the end of our two Suzaku actually
assumes the role of zero from the luge
and we also know that throughout the
series c2 impersonates Lelouch on
multiple occasions as zero this idea
came mostly from soul maka but the
theory is that someone could assume the
role of zero impersonate zero in order
to frame him in some terrible deeds so
let's say someone is interested in
starting a civil war related to the
previous point they could impersonate
zero do something in his name that
creates a terrible conflict and destroys
the zero Requiem
if this happens in the sequel it would
be an interesting twist and again it
would be one of those things that would
surely force Lelouch to come out of
hiding in order to fight against this
zero imposter number five the return of
Charles after being absorbed by C's
world in r2 could Charles potentially
return in a non physical form to become
the main villain once again in the OVA
Akito the exiled a being with code
manifests in a non physical or spiritual
form and explains that she is a
representation of pure consciousness
since we know that Charles spent decades
studying the world of C and the power of
code and Geass so could he somehow
manipulate the world of C in order to
appear once again in non-physical form
in order to appear as pure consciousness
shout-out to Briggs from all de anime
for helping me out on this one and well
this is an interesting theory I
personally hope it doesn't happen I know
that a lot of you guys were talking in
the chat and in the comments that you
think schnozzle or one of the old
villains might play an important role in
the sequel but I personally hope that
that doesn't happen
those guys Charles Nigel they're old
news I want to see new more interesting
and more powerful villains so I'm hoping
that that's what's going to have
number four new forms and higher levels
of Geass a lot of you guys mentioned
that new forms of Geass power could be
featured in the sequel including Blu
Geass green Diaz and of course Super
Saiyan God Geass okay maybe not the last
one but we do know that Leila from a key
to the exile has a special kind of Geass
that manifests as blue and that she
actually got from c-2 when she was still
a child we also know that Jeremiah
Gottwald or orange has an artificial
Geass canceler that also manifests as
blue except whereas Leila's Geass sign
in her eye is actually right-side up
orange is Geass sign is upside down and
in the new PV or teaser trailer for the
Code Geass sequel we see what looks like
Lelouch is I and it appears to briefly
flash green before turning the normal
Geass color and this has led a lot of
people to speculate that perhaps Green
is a sign of a higher level of Geass
than Lelouch has achieved I think this
is very possible and I will definitely
like to see new and higher forms of
Geass featured in the sequel I also
think that we could see other forms of
artificial Geass emerge in the sequel
especially if it features a big civil
war or conflict because think about it
if you can mass produce artificial Geass
power you could create an army of Geass
users that would definitely be a big
threat to Lelouch and to the black
knights something like that would
certainly force the lose to reach a
higher level of Geass and I would
definitely like to see something like
that in the sequel like I said a lot of
you guys commented on this and thank you
all very much
number three the ancient origins of code
and Geass in the original series it is
established that the eight thought
elevators that are scattered around the
globe and that Charles uses to activate
the Ragnarok connection were actually
built by a mysterious ancient
civilization of beings with code in
order to build these powerful structures
this ancient civilization must have been
very advanced and it actually reminds me
of the whole Atlantis myth in our own
world in fact I believe that this frame
from the scene where Lelouch first makes
a contract with c2 in the very first
episode of Code Geass actually shows the
members of this ancient civilization you
can
they have the code sign on their
foreheads and their clothing also looks
ancient you can see that this clothing
is different from any of the modern
clothing that we see in the world of
Code Geass and it is also very different
from the clothing that is used by the
modern Geass order which was established
by Charles and v2 in fact in the new PV
we also see shots of what looked like
two ancient temples which seems to
suggest that the ancient origins of
Geass and the civilization that first
created the thought elevators could be
an important part of the sequel
shout-out to Charles Cisneros on this
one
number two ancient aliens in the same
scene where Lelouch gets his Geass from
c-2 for the first time the next frame we
see after the members of that ancient
civilization is what looks like a planet
in outer space could this planet be a
clue about the ancient civilization that
created the thought elevators in the
first place are these beings actually
aliens who colonized multiple planets
and do they possess alien technology
that could make them a brand new threat
to the world of Code Geass I first
mentioned this ancient aliens theory in
a previous video and if you want to
check that one out the link is in the
description so you can find it there
Lelouch VI Britannia himself commented
that he thinks that the planet shown in
the frame is actually Jupiter all hail
Lelouch in the first episode of r2 when
c2 helps the louche break Charles's
Geass we actually see a close-up of this
same planet with the Sun in the
background the planet does indeed look a
lot like Jupiter and the same planet
also appears in seas world as the
representation of the collective
consciousness or God but why Jupiter
what is the meaning of Jupiter in this
context I actually found an article on
astrology calm that could be helpful the
article says the following Jupiter is
the thinking persons planet as the
guardian of the abstract mind this
planet rules higher learning and bestows
upon us a yen for exploring ideas both
intellectually and spiritually
intellectually speaking Jupiter assists
us in formulating our ideology
in the more spiritual realm Jupiter
lords over religions and philosophy a
search for the answers is what Jupiter
proposes and if it means spanning the
globe to find them well that's probably
why Jupiter also rules long distance
travel now this seems to say a lot to me
because if you think about it sees world
is all about pure consciousness
collective consciousness collective
unconscious right so abstract thinking
philosophical moral ideas these are all
things that Charles is definitely
obsessed with that Charles clashes with
Lelouch with so the symbolism is real
even the whole thing about Jupiter
searching scouring the globe for answers
seems to represent the eight thought
elevators that was scattered around the
globe and Charles spent his life
studying them so that he can activate
the Ragnarok connection so now the
question is whether showing us Jupiter
is just symbolic or whether it means
something more whether it means that
there are beings with code on other
planets and that perhaps they even
created thought elevators on these other
planets and that long distance travel
through space might actually be a part a
crucial part of the plot in the sequel
we don't know for sure yet but I really
think that these are interesting
questions so I hope that the sequel
gives us some answers and number one the
ancient beings who created code and
Geass have advanced beyond physical form
and they now want to destroy all of
humanity as I mentioned earlier in the
final episode of Akito the exiled a
being with code appears to the main
character Layla in spiritual form and
explains that she and others like her
are representations of the collective
consciousness rather than humans
themselves and she even states that
humans would Geass only possess a small
fragment of Geass power the actual power
of Geass is far greater than humans can
imagine this
makes us wonder if these ancient beings
with code became so advanced that they
moved beyond physical form and became a
collective consciousness much like the
anti spirals in Gurren Lagann this same
being iñaki to the exiled actually
implies that humans are not worthy of
the power of Geass so what if just like
the anti spirals in Gurren Lagann
thinking that humans are too dangerous
and have to be destroyed to protect the
universe what if these ancient beings
conclude the humans are unworthy of
using Geass that they are too dangerous
and that the entire human race must be
eradicated the ancient beings might come
to this conclusion because Charles
decided to mess with the eighth thought
elevators and to activate the Ragnarok
connection like our friend there
caffeinate er pointed out in his comment
I think that something like this would
be the most shocking and the most
interesting twist that could possibly
happen in the sequel a powerful race of
beings with code that is advanced beyond
physical form the size that the human
race deserves to be eradicated something
like this would certainly force Lelouch
to come out of hiding and to face these
beings head-on because now he would not
only be protecting Nunnally and his
friends he would have to protect the
entire human race now wouldn't that be
an interesting way of raising the stakes
for the sequel and those were the 10
wildest theories that we came up with
together for Code Geass season 3 if you
have any theories of your own that we
didn't mention be sure to leave them in
the comments because we'd love to hear
from you and if you'd like to be a part
of future discussions and featured in
future videos be sure to subscribe and
if you enjoyed this video make sure you
like it and share it with your friends
so many of you guys have been active on
the channel lately and you made this
video possible and it really means a lot
to us thank you
and along with everyone else that we
mention in the video I want to also give
a quick shout out to Mackel not buck
here and zero for zoo pond wc3
creep Elin dark sonic 786 Ladoga beam
beam Rafael rays misty flair 19 Hani al
Zahrani
Akio unknown miss coeds and purr breed
sing thanks a lot everybody and you will
find the full list of contributors and
there's a lot of them in the description
making
this video was a lot of fun chatting
with you guys was a lot of fun and I
can't wait to do it again and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]